Now you have a statistic in my book
where I mentioned that it was the
average income of the parents of our
value university undergrad students
right now corresponds to the average
income of the top two percent of the US
distribution of family income.
So this doesn't mean that everybody at
outcomes from the two percent,
you have some people who come from below
youtube too,
but there are so few and so people who
come from the top two are so that the
overall average is as if all students
had been picked up from them within the
top two.
I think this is an example where the gap
between the official discourse based on
meritocracy call opportunity,
mobility of us society,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And the reality is particularly strong.
So I think there's a lot of fight crazy
basie elite not only in the US but also
in my country in France.
You know,
we don't have this very high tuition
fees,
but we are sometimes able to put the
five times more public resources in the
schools where the children of the elite
go to as compared to the.
So you know,
in every country there's a lot of
hypocrisy about equal opportunity and an
incredible abilities and time of the
elite to justify inequality as fair when
it is not fair.
And I think what's important is to put
all these claims under public scrutiny
and to have more transparency,
not only about income and wealth,
but also about who benefits from what
public spendings so that we can adapt
our policies.